he was the 13th overall pick out of San
Diego State in the 1969 draft and had in
his 13 seasons in the National Football
League sacks been kept as a stat his
hundred and four career sacks would
currently ranked 28th all-time he is
Fred Dreyer here on the show good to see
you Frank you very much rich great to be
here you bet so when you showed up
in 1969 rookie you were with the New
York Giants and Fran Tarkenton was there
and obviously the mayor of family Jones
what was that like for for the kid just
coming out of college and suddenly
you're thrown in the NFL 1969 there's
the New York Giants organization well
the one thing I kept thinking flying in
was I'm going to see Yankee Stadium
tomorrow
yeah and they I went up to ten Columbus
Circle talked with long Tamara the owner
and and then Jim tremble at the time was
working in personality he took the train
out to Yankee Stadium the four train or
the D train or something Lexington
Avenue sure yeah that's the train it
just jumped us right off in left field
you know we just walked out went right
through the back door you know and and
so I remember going into the Yankee
dugout and seeing the white rug and in
the blue line why and looking around and
seeing all the empty lockers and then
this is in January of 70 right after I
was right after in 69 when I was drafted
and and then we walked down the little
tunnel ended up into the Yankee a first
base dugout and then up onto the top
step and I remember looking out at left
field and realizing that if you were
standing during a Yankee game and you
were standing in the dugout you couldn't
see the third baseman because the field
dropped off mm-hmm so you can see all
the infielders except for the third
basement so I was noticing all these
interesting things it was a cold drizzly
day and I sprinted out over second base
into centerfield to see the drain pipe
the Mickey Mantle stepped in when he
tore up his name and I said do you mean
to tell me
it's still here so do you think they
kept that thing pull it out yeah so I so
all through my rookie here you know the
the way the the field was set up in yet
in the old Yankee Stadium was a football
field was set up just to the left of the
drain so the drain was actually
underneath of this bench okay in center
field sure and every time I be put every
time we play a game you know and we I've
always kind of find my way over to the
in front of the visitors bench and I
remember telling that Bill Bradley who
was a safety for Philadelphia
I say hey Bill you know right over there
is where nikki Haley is really so we had
this conversation during the game was
great old school stuff man and then you
came to the Los Angeles Rams in 1977 me
too so anything that was just at the
beginning of a huge stretch here in Los
Angeles football what is what was your
memory of walking into the locker room
for first time this Jack Youngblood who
was just four fresh off the campus of
Florida Merlin Olsen right in the mix
what I like joining joining that group
Fred it was a it was terrific because I
was born and raised in Los Angeles and
in 1958 I was 12 and my father took my
brother and I to go see my first RAM
game at the Coliseum with the Bears
it was also the same year that the
Dodgers moved into the Coliseum to play
their first season here in LA so it was
a great thing for me
and to finally come full circle and play
for my home team one of the first things
I did when I the first preseason game in
72 I came down the tunnel and made a
beeline right into the end zone and went
right down what would be the third-base
side via the cutout dugout cut out the
baseball field to Coliseum and went
right over to the edge and and up and
talked to two people who sat in the same
seats as I did when I was a kid okay
watching dodge again yeah it was a great
moment it was and that's the first thing
I thought about going to the stadium
getting dressed and I mean wouldn't wait
to get out
instances going to the Giants in the
ranch you're talking about a baseball
configuration of the stadiums and yeah
that's right yeah and it was a it was a
great experience and you know the beauty
of it is everybody was naive culture was
naive in the sense and and I was I was
terribly naive but so eager when I got
to New York that really make the best of
it and and take part in the great
franchise it's still a great franchise
certainly but at that time you know I
was asked you know many times over the
over the years was your biggest thrill I
said the greatest thrill was being 23
and playing in Yankee Stadium greatest
and then you played for the Los Angeles
Rams I want to take a break when we come
back in 60 seconds you're you're here to
talk about battle the Network Stars at
UVA now and two different iterations of
the show the current one on ABC the the
Howard Cosell version back in the day I
want to know what the tug of war was
like with telly savalas
when you were it was like hunter versus
getting older as these become on now
Fred and then I do want to ask you some
more football questions Fred dryer when
we come back in 60 seconds here in the
Richardson
hundreds of for career sacks 153
episodes of hunter one man Fred dryer
back here in the Rich Eisen show I'm a
double - million you are that Fred so
would you have gotten into acting if you
didn't come play for the LA Rams do you
think oh yeah you would have yeah yeah
well I you know I I was fortunate you
know I I had many interests and I could
have gone a couple different ways you
know real estate development I had real
estate and when I was playing with the
Rams I did real estate while you're
playing yeah I bought properties and did
stuff you know I've gotten so I simply
amassed a bunch of stuff you know and I
say well I can go that direction I can
go into I can go into acting I think I
didn't have any idea how to go do that
at that time on 72 73 you know but I had
a vision for myself outside of playing
football you know you can only do that
sport for maybe two and a half three
years before you realize I I got a
dotted line around my neck I could go
down any time you know so you have to
you have to figure it out and and and
navigate your way through this life and
use the football the sports experience
for for a stepping stone to get where
you want to go and so I always knew that
I had an acting interest when I when I
moved to LA I immediately in 72 I jumped
into acting classes so I was doing a
bunch of stuff real estate yeah acting
class yes Los Angeles rang out while I
was playing and and certainly in this
offseason you know I would I would not
mitt waste any time I just I just went
from one thing to another any when I got
fired in 81 I couldn't wait to get into
my card and come up to LA to my
Attorney's office in Westwood and just
simply say okay let's go we got stuff to
do and and let's move it that direction
did you ever talk about it with Merlin
Olsen father Murphy and we were we were
uh we were roommates on the road you
know and so for four years you know I
got to know him pretty good
and we talked about a lot of stuff and
he was in he was in the process what was
interesting is I was able to see and
talk to him a little bit without being
too nosy about his transition you know
Merlin didn't Merlin didn't at the time
want to be able to be seen as someone
who was in conflict while he was playing
he didn't want someone to say you know
you know well you know he's only here
for another year or two before now he's
going to get a big TV deal how can you
sack the quarterback if your little
house is on the prayer he was Oliver he
was so well professional and it was it
was just great to be around him and we
talked a little bit about that yeah yeah
and then 1976 comes all right so you're
playing you're playing in the Super Bowl
in the Rose Bowl 79 79 was when that
happened right okay see 76 comes and
gusts the kicking mule if the silver
screen was that your big Disney's movie
was the autos and other stuff before you
are before the kicking field goals on
key and I swear I'll be tell you
something yeah he can kick come on now
he could kick hold on a second yeah he
could kick that was we used to laugh it
up a pulled out every ex football player
in town they emptied all the bars out
but buckets was in it too right
everybody was in it it was hilarious
we're in the locker room getting dressed
up and and everybody started laughing
because it was so funny it looked like a
you know looked like a huge parking lot
get together but you know before you
know one of one of the guys was going to
get married or something it was a huge
tailgate and we even struck for better
wages so you're saying
hold on a minute Gus the kicking mule
yeah I'd really kick if you kick the
meal could that was not some sort of you
know extremely stupid animal but it was
a strong you put a football in front of
him he knew what to do okay and so you
and Butkus and who are the other players
oh god it was Deacon there was I mean
there was every Joker Rolo everybody it
ever lived in out California the played
for somebody and you got together and
said to Disney we want
our money well yeah because it was long
hours okay so we say hey look you know I
mean let you get what you wanted when we
got a bump what was the last residual
check you got from Gus - kicking me old
front that dried up that whole dried up
about 22 years although I do get checks
I still make a joke about it I do get
checks on the some of the first things I
ever did I was there was a it was a
movie I did and in the in the mid 70s I
think I might have been 76 yeah because
I had a beard at that time there was a
guy sold on I've got your the Fred dryer
IMDB page up right here he'll say well
it says you did I mean said you did Gus
and then the next thing you did was play
a lifeguard in Laverne and Shirley
I did that you know and then you were in
Lou Grant who by the way played by Ed
Asner who was the coach of Gus to kick
yes he was and we talked a lot about
that we talked about the Homburg and a
donkey thanks about your donkey review
and I'm a set of Lou Grant you're
talking about Gus the kicking mule yeah
Lou you were in chips yep the rau stirs
hard to heart oh yeah okay oh yeah and
then came hunter yeah I got a fight with
Robert Wagner Bob Riga he says please
call me RJ for it as I knocked him out
you know I called my Jack with it with a
real real hit no it was it my character
was a murderer and he you know he chases
me up on the roof and we had a big you
know wrestling match yeah but uh but
just went in there yeah I'm looking at
your Louise's and there's an independent
film in there I don't see it that's how
independent it is quite all right but
you know I looked at gradual I looked at
that a couple years ago and I could say
wasn't missing a bunch of stuff I
usually just looking at everything you
got right here a bunch of stuff on and
then Hunter I mean that was a hell of a
run what's funny you said the rosters
that was a pilot Steve Channel didn't
for ABC I think it was yeah and robert
davi and i were were were cast as crazed
twins wait a minute I'm identical twins
you know like like a split pea group
yeah in peewee here's how nuts
I am Delta folk you know who Robert Davi
is he's the one in diehard who told him
that you lose the grid or you lose your
job the FBI AJ yeah who came on the
scene this is how nuts I am Fred know
was good I was built for this
conversation I was built for this
football in pop culture give me all your
guys because we can go all there so
anyway no I got the hunter interview yes
because of my work with Bob on the
rosters on this on this two-hour movie
so there would be no hunter if it wasn't
for the rosters I won't say that okay I
do know that I was floating around town
they said how about that guy well me
okay bring him in who is well you know
half the people my first couple years
was very frustrating because I would get
calls to come out and read for stuff and
I'd walk over I'd like there like
everybody else you know you have you
know you have your sides and you're
looking at it enough the guy says okay
come on in and you walk in and there's
35 people in there and all they wanted
to do was talk about the Rams that's it
so I read this that's okay and now
you're in battle of the Network Stars
have Thursday 8:00 9:00 Eastern on ABC
you were in the original battle Network
says what you got I blow sell story from
Messiah hold it well you know how our
idea I love the cigars and up and so
we're out at Malibu which is where we
were for this one yes but we were out at
the Malibu campus and I was talking with
my girlfriend at the time and she's seen
some friends who were who were in the
actual contest and so Howard's out there
with he's out to his Gifford this was
part of Wide World of Sports sure yeah
and so it was a whole hole up a roster
of great Network people and then a lot
of present-day TV stars you know and
Howard's out there holding court he's
got a cigar and he's trembling
now it's two hours ago and of course you
know I I come over to him and I said hey
Howard
you know I've just done kind of a
citizen's poll here and they all want
you to leave that's not gonna happen
today as always my favorite you know
that the Monday Night Football guy but
this the Monday night baseball guy and
he would be here comes Bob Conrad
leading the team and BC without the
battery taking on telly savalas Kojak
himself with Gabe Kaplan oh my god I'm
telling it's really this conversation is
really good this is good this oh gosh
come back any time man oh right dryer
coat check out highway 395 which is a
feature film that you directed and
started at Fred Rio check that out check
out Battle Network Stars Thursday 9:00
Eastern on ABC yep please let's come
back we've only scratched the surface
just give me one all we can control all
day long about how it's beautiful I love
that right dryer here on the Rich Eisen
show don't you dare move we'll probably
show up in a moment the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that Gelman around please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the Rich Eisen show app you
need that